hola
quiero comentarles una forma no
convencional que tengo de darme cuenta
si un candidato o candidata tiene la
actitud adecuada para una posición
quieren saber mi secreto
excelente aquí va el secreto miren
después de una jornada de entrevistas
siempre me gusta preguntarle a la
persona de recepción al conserje a la
persona de seguridad cómo fue la
interacción de los candidatos con ellos
si ellos saludaron si ellos se
despidieron si agradecieron un gesto o
un vaso con agua
eso me dice muchísimo de las personas
que estoy buscando para un empleo se
podrían sorprender de la cantidad de
información y cómo una persona
esparce su marca personal en un proceso
de reclutamiento y selección
y si hoy por hoy tuviera que hacer un
ranking de los errores que se cometen
hay uno que se hace muy común de parte
de los profesionales y es que muchas
personas envían su currículum
lo adjuntan y no colocan ni un saludo
estar del otro lado
y recibir un correo que sólo tiene un
adjunto
es algo que realmente me llama mucho la
atención
yo puedo interpretar de hecho lo
interpretó puede ser que sea una persona
no muy amable que no sea muy educada o
que sea una persona que
no esté enfocada y enfocado en los
detalles con un solo gesto me dice
muchísimo
y aquí la actitud es a la personalidad
lo que la ropa es al cuerpo
y le pregunto con qué actitud picks de
su personalidad la actitud la marca
personal lo es todo y qué tan
conscientes estamos de ello
es muy difícil muy difícil casi
imposible que aunque tenga cantidad de
títulos aunque tenga muy buenas
habilidades aunque tenga mucha
experiencia laboral pero sí es una
persona que no tiene una buena actitud
es muy difícil que construye una buena
marca personal o alguna vez alguna vez
han escuchado que buen estudiante es
ella pero tiene muy mala actitud o qué
buen jefe es esa persona sabe muchísimo
pero nos trata súper mal
es imposible calificar a alguien como
bueno o excelente si con su actitud no
lo es de una forma integral
tom peters es un gurú en los negocios es
el padre del concepto de marca personal
y tom peters revolucionó el mundo de los
negocios con su concepto en los 90 de
marca personal el inicialmente su
objetivo en sus estudios era ayudar a
las personas que buscaban un empleo a
distinguirse
pero luego su concepto evolucionó
muchísimo más entonces con pires decía
cualquiera puede ser una marca todos
podemos ser una empresa todos podemos
ser nuestra propia empresa y es lo
conceptualizó diciendo que podríamos ser
nuestro yo es sea pero siempre siempre
enfatizó que para lograr eso se tenía
que tener una actitud que nos hiciera
distinguirlos de los demás una actitud
que nos hiciera inolvidables
en la universidad de stanford se hizo
una es un estudio muy interesante con
unos niños
240 niños de edades de 7 a 10 años su
estudio fue muy muy peculiar ellos
querían investigar qué tanto se
relacionaba la actitud de los
estudiantes con la actitud hacia la
matemática ellos utilizaron diferentes
máquinas de resonancia magnética en los
niños y les pidieron a ellos que
mientras estaban en este proceso y
desarrollaran un ejercicio de aritmética
básica que encontraron bueno como era de
esperarse los niños que les gustaban las
demás las matemáticas ellos obtuvieron
mejores calificaciones en el en el
ejercicio los niños que no les encantaba
la materia que no les gustaba sacaron
los resultados más bajos pero lo
fascinante de este estudio fue que los
escáneres cerebrales
encontraron algo sumamente increíble que
es por ejemplo una área del cerebro que
es el hipocampo que está asociada con la
aprendiz con el aprendizaje de la
memoria se activaba significativamente
en aquellos estudiantes que tenían una
excelente actitud hacia la materia
independientemente de la aptitud que
tuvieran y tenían buenos resultados
entonces los investigadores concluyeron
y dijeron realmente el desempeño escolar
un buen desempeño escolar está
relacionado con la actitud la buena
actitud que tengan los estudiantes
fortún phandroid hizo otro estudio muy
recientemente también que fue muy
revelador y entrevistaron a diferentes
ejecutivos de diferentes industrias y
ellos dentro de una de las preguntas
claves que les hicieron identificaban el
94 por ciento de ellos que atribuían su
éxito a su actitud más que a otros
factores
entonces
como vemos lo anterior si queremos
alcanzar nuestras metas nuestros sueños
definitivamente tenemos que tener una
buena actitud y cómo lograr tener una
actitud que construya una marca personal
enriquecida yo traigo 6 recomendaciones
basadas en experiencia y en las
vivencias que he logrado tener alrededor
de los años con otras personas
mi primera recomendación es que tenga
una actitud 360 qué quiero decir con eso
sea su mejor versión donde sea que usted
esté en la universidad en el trabajo con
su familia con sus amistades donde sea
que usted esté sea positivo o positiva
como estilo de vida es fácil ser
positivo cuando las cosas van bien el
gran mérito es ser positivo o positiva
cuando las cosas marchan mal es ahí
donde nosotros necesitamos
aflorar esa positividad para que nos
vaya bien
construyan relaciones sólidas sean
relaciones que usted hizo desde hace
mucho tiempo sea
persona con personas que usted acaba de
conocer siempre traté de dejar una muy
buena interacción busque servir a través
de esas relaciones sólidas busque dar
ese valor agregado
haga todo lo que venga a sus manos con
excelencia no importa que tan pequeña
qué tan grande sea hágalo todo con
excelencia que esté impregnada su
esencia en cada cosa que usted hace
nutra su marca personal que su renueva
su renovación se vuelva su pasión su
continua renovación
desarrolle la autoconciencia como hábito
diario cuando uno tiene autoconciencia
uno tiene un poder sobre sí mismo y hay
muchas formas de desarrollar esta
autoconciencia una de esas maneras es
pedir retroalimentación a personas que
queremos o que nos quieren que nos
pueden dar una opinión sincera que
pueden aportar algo a nuestra vida y es
tía pero aquí hay algo muy importante
cuando pidamos retroalimentación no lo
tomemos en la ligera realmente anotemos
y hagamos acciones y no se vale enojarse
algo que recomiendo también es llevar un
diario y si no es de ustedes escribir y
de llevar un diario por lo menos tome un
tiempo donde usted pueda reflexionar qué
fue lo que hizo bien y no es tanto de un
tiempo de para flagelarse y disculparse
por algo que hizo mal sino más bien en
que puedo mejorar
y mi sexta recomendación es no sea
víctima
hace muchos años 19 años para ser
exactos me convertí en mamá soy mamá
joven dejo a mi hija emilia que tiene 19
años en este momento tengo a mi hijo
marquito jose que tiene 3 años y tengo
alberto que viene en camino tengo 32
semanas
volviendo en esos tiempos siendo mamá
joven
pues fue muy fácil que muchas personas
me juzgarán o dijeron aquí es la vida de
estas muchachas e aquí quedó en la nada
verdad el pase de situaciones bien
difíciles porque tal vez gente que yo
quería incluso familia muy cercana me
dieron la espalda otras personas no pero
una persona que quiero mucho me dio un
consejo yo esperaba unas palabras de
aliento un abrazo un apapacho y me dijo
no sea víctima salga adelante
esas palabras quiero que sepan que me
molestaron muchísimo en ese momento yo
quería ser víctima quería que me tuviera
lástima esa persona pero no no pasó así
resonó en mi cabeza por meses
pero luego
tuve un despertar
y dije no no voy a ser víctima voy a
hacer la heroína de mi historia
y saben que aprendí 19 años después que
la vida me iba a dar un montón de
situaciones difíciles que iba a tener
que afrontar y tomar la decisión si yo
iba a ser una víctima o una heroína y
saben que en cada circunstancia difícil
siempre elegí ser la heroína de mi
historia
ahora con todo este tema de la actitud
quiero darles una muy buena noticia
la buena noticia es que si hoy en día
usted identifica cosas que usted tiene
que cambiar lo puede hacer nunca es
tarde para cambiar
nunca es tarde para para renovarse si
usted toma la decisión y lo acompaña con
acciones diarias usted lo puede lograr
ahora
quiero preguntarles que deja su actitud
en otros cuando usted interactúa con
otras personas cuál es la esencia que
usted deja cuál es ese aroma es
agradable las demás personas quedan con
algo positivo de usted o lo opuesto
cuando parta de esta tierra
qué marca habrá dejado en los demás
en su familia en sus amigos en sus
colegas de trabajo en su equipo en sus
hijos
quiero comentarles que
mi madre es una persona que siempre va a
inspirar mi vida ella trabajó 40 años en
el rubro de la salud y los últimos 30
años estuvo como director a un hospital
en tegucigalpa y ella se dedicó a servir
a servir a sus pacientes a servir a sus
colegas a su equipo de trabajo ella
construyó una
con su actitud construyó una marca que
dejó una esencia importante en los demás
mi madre
hace ya casi nueve meses
se enfermó de kobe y mi mamá falleció
después de 30 días de una valiente
batalla ella partió
dentro de las infinitas muestras de
cariño que obtuve hubo un mensaje que me
impactó muchísimo
y fue este
esta fue la sala donde mi mamá estuvo y
él una persona que fue subalterno de
ella y yo mientras miraba ese mensaje
dije me puse a analizar
cuántas actitudes tan positivas tuvo mi
madre diariamente como impacto ella con
su esencia
entonces le pregunto a usted hoy en día
cuál es la marca que deja usted en los
demás y por qué eso es importante porque
su actitud como han analizado muchos
filósofos y pensadores
determina su altitud
y si bien es cierto los títulos de
experiencia laboral y las habilidades
van a enriquecer le
pero su actitud una buena actitud va a
marcar el camino al éxito
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah